elon musk is known to have beef with a
lot of people he says he's not the
biggest fan of warren buffett he's
blasted mark zuckerberg's meta andy
frequently pokes fun at jeff bezos jeff
who
[Laughter]
but one guy he really really really
doesn't like is martin eberhard one of
tesla's co-founders he's the worst
person i have ever worked with and that
is saying something okay i've worked
with some real [ __ ] the two have
squabbled over who actually founded
tesla i'm not sure why he has to also
say that he was a founder when he wasn't
i don't understand that oh yeah whatever
it'd be accurate to say that there were
like five co-founders of tesla and he
counts himself as one of them martin
eberhard and fellow engineer mark
tarpening incorporated tesla motors in
2003. ian wright jb strabal and elon
musk join later however musk believes
there's no way tesla would have even
gone into production without him and jb
straubel its chief technology officer
musk pushed eberhard out of his role as
ceo and eventually out of the company in
2007 by then musk had been with tesla
for three years he used his earnings
from paypal to sign on as one of the
first investors in tesla in 2004 and
became chairman of the board
so why does elon musk despise martin
eberhard he even went so far as to say i
wish i had never met him
he believes eberhard nearly drove the
company into the ground when trying to
produce tesla's first car the roadster
you can have a car that's quick and you
can have a car it's electric but having
one that's both is how you make electric
cars popular trouble is musk didn't
think eberhard was capable of building
an electric sports car he says eberhard
wanted to outsource car battery
production to a barbecue manufacturing
factory in thailand as they were having
trouble finding a factory willing to
produce an advanced lithium-ion battery
pack when a tesla team went over to
check out the factory instead of a
factory they found a concrete slab with
posts holding up a roof as ashley vance
detailed in his book about elon musk
since the thai company couldn't make a
battery pack it caused issues for the
rest of the supply chain the plan was to
have the battery cells made in japan
shipped to thailand where they were
turned into a battery pack then shipped
to england where a company called lotus
engineering would build the body of the
car and attach the battery pack before
making its way to the initial market in
california musk alleges eberhard screwed
up in other areas too he says he
outsourced the carbon fiber body panels
to a company that couldn't make them
carbon fiber is a special material it's
very strong for it's very lightweight he
said the gaps between the body panels
were so big you could put your thumb in
between them unfortunately i don't have
pictures of the original roadster's body
panel issues but here are photos someone
posted on twitter of a model 3 with
large gaps between the panels
possibly the greatest mistake tesla made
in the early days was deciding on the
transmission system for the roadster
musk says eberhard refused to change the
motor size so to achieve 0 to 60 as
quickly as possible without a bigger
motor they required a 2-speed
transmission rather than a single speed
one the first gear would take the car
from 0-60 in less than 4 seconds the
second gear would take the car up to 130
miles an hour however the transmission
couldn't handle the jump from the first
gear to the second eberhard had vowed to
begin shipping the roadster in late 2007
but there was no way that could happen
with the transmission issues actually
the original plan was to deliver the car
in 2006. in the end production for the
roadster didn't begin until the fall of
2008. eberhard has responded to musk's
criticism in a message to me he wrote
that is of course ridiculous sure we
were over budget and behind schedule
which successful startup companies were
not
he went on to say since i left tesla 14
years ago which of tesla's cars has been
on schedule or on budget how is that
cyber truck going in reference to
tesla's futuristic truck musket said it
would make it to market by the end of
2021 but has now been delayed until 2023
musk also accuses eberhard of
intentionally deceiving him about the
true cost of the roadster when one of
tesla's investors sent its managing
director to do an audit they found that
the cost of producing the sports car
would be a hundred twenty thousand well
above the selling price of ninety two
thousand eberhart had said it would cost
65 000 to make tesla had already taken
deposits from hundreds of customers
promising the car would cost less than a
hundred thousand enough was enough and
as the roadster was way over budget and
late musk got on the phone with eberhard
and told him the board had decided he'd
be replaced as ceo demoting him to the
role of president of technology in
mid-2007 while keeping the same 200 000
salary he made as ceo eberhard was
pissed off and by the year's end he had
left the company all together i was
voted off the island and in in a rather
rude way tesla named michael marks as
interim ceo followed by permanent ceo
zev jarrory a silicon valley
semiconductor veteran before musk took
over the top job in the fall of 2008.
musk may have blamed eberhard for
tesla's troubles however eberhard has
blamed musk for the roadster's problems
in this newsweek article from 2008
eberhard accused musk of interfering
with the design of the car demanding
changes that were costly and led to
delays these included installing
electronic door latches building a
lightweight carbon fiber body and
lowering the door sill by two inches
musk denied that those changes were the
cause of the delays in told fortune
magazine he was quote too busy trying to
fix the bleeping mess he as an eberhard
left in 2009 eberhard sued musk alleging
musk began a pattern of defaming and
disparaging him in the media the lawsuit
also states musk set out to rewrite
history by falsely claiming that he was
the founder or creator of tesla motors
when someone on twitter pointed out musk
was not the founder musk argued founding
means more than filing papers to start a
company he says without him tesla motors
had no employees no ip address no
designs no prototype literally nothing
but a business plan
in its counter claim against eberhard
tesla and musk dismissed eberhard's
lawsuit as quote nothing more than to
curb open discourse on matters of
importance to the public and to extract
money from tesla in the end they agreed
to a settlement elon musk jb strabal and
ian wright were allowed to call
themselves co-founders alongside mark
tarpening and martin eberhard by the way
eberhard mentioned in his lawsuit that
he didn't receive the second roadster
tesla ever produced as promised which
musk sold to a friend the one he did
finally get had been smashed into the
back of a truck by an employee during an
endurance test almost completely
totaling the vehicle it was a wreck
perhaps a metaphor for the relationship
between musk and eberhard
after leaving tesla everhard briefly led
volkswagen's evie development in the us
was the vp of ativa which is now lucid
motors for only six weeks and also ran
his own electric startup now he's
enjoying retirement while enjoying it as
much as he can except when musk brings
up his name i just buy his money heart
eberhard ended his message to me by
saying i find it strange that musk feels
he must still spend his energy
criticizing me when my startup company
with all its flaws has revolutionized
the entire automotive industry and has
made musk the richest man in the world
i'd like to take the opportunity to
thank the sponsor of this video
magnesium breakthrough by by optimizers
i used to have a lot of trouble sleeping
but ever since i've been taking
magnesium breakthrough since the start
of this year i've noticed that i've just
gotten much better sleep which has
allowed me to better focus especially
when i make videos that demand a lot of
my time and energy what makes magnesium
breakthrough stand out is that there are
no synthetic ingredients all of the
ingredients are naturally derived when
you get all seven critical forms of
magnesium as you do with magnesium
breakthrough your body gets a serious
upgrade so you can feel better
throughout your day to find out more
head to magnesiumbreakthrough.com
newsthink to get a 10 discount my custom
link is in my description and pin
comment and don't forget to use my promo
code newsthink10 at checkout thanks for
watching for newsthink i'm cindy palm